Qui je suis ? Euh, je suis Valérie ayez.
Ayez, merci d'avoir bien prononcé mon nom de famille.
J'ai 37 ans, je viens de la Mayenne.
J'ai la chance d'avoir grandi dans 1 ferme
avec ma sœur et mon frère.
Mes parents étaient agriculteurs.
Je me suis engagée très jeune dans la vie politique
puisque je suis devenue conseillère
municipale de mon village
à vingt-et-un ans.
En deux-mille-dix-sept, j'ai rejoint Emmanuel Macron.
En deux-mille-dix-neuf,
j'ai eu la chance de devenir députée européenne.
J'ai beaucoup travaillé depuis au Parlement européen
et je suis aujourd'hui, euh.
Président du groupe central
au Parlement européen.
C'est le groupe, euh. Des alliés d'Emmanuel Macron.